ま、結局反映する会社はやっぱり経営者
でしょ。人というものに対して価値を認め
ずに投用できない。採用もできない。全く
大きくならないまま終わっちゃうだろうな
。今の世の中に何が必要なのかという
ところに立したビジネスを掘り下げていく
方がきっと発展反映するんではないかと僕
は信じてますけどね。青木久里の人生鉄学
100回聞いたら豊かになる話。
今回はですね、年少
1億円、そして10億円。50
億円を超えていく会社に
見えない共通点というものがあるとしたらどんな共通点があるか青木社長の考えをお聞かせいただけますでしょうか?
[音楽]
ま、シンプルにまず社会の自流に乗ってるよね。
社会の求めに応じて努力をしてるよね。
そしてやっぱり経営者自身が向上心志し
持ってると思うよ。別に心志しっていう
言葉使わなくても願望がやっぱりその経営
者として自分なりにこういう会社にして
いきたいとかまそれは画欲も多少ある人も
いるだろうけれども明らかに社会ニーズが
あある仕事についていてそしてま適正能力
を本人が持っていてそして優秀な人材を集
めることができ、パートナーに恵まれ、
ある意味で健全な体力を持ちながら努力し
続けてる人間は当然発展反映していくと
思うんですよ。うん。でもやっぱり世の中
に必要とされない仕事をしていたり、それ
からやっぱり心志しが低くて自分さえ
良ければいいっていうような考え方がもし
カにあってだからなんかこう個人自分の
そこそこほどほどの収入で満足していたり
それから人というものに対して価値を認め
ずに投用できない。それから採用もでき
ない。あとはやっぱり世の中に求められる
商品を開発できない。作っても売ることへ
の熱意がない。そしたらもう
全く大きくならないまま終わっちゃう
だろうな。会社ってのはもう10年以内に
もう本当3割とか5割の会社が消えちゃう
わけじゃん。昔はあの7割消えてたんだよ
。だんだんだんだんやっぱり時代の流れと
共にね、生まれる会社の数も少なくなった
分、潰れる会社も少なくなってきて、ま、
大体でもそれでも10年経ったら半分
ぐらいなくなっちゃうんだよね。
ぶっちゃけ。でも外食なんてのはもっと
早くなくなっちゃいます。業種業によるん
だけど。ま、結局反映する会社はやっぱり
経営者でしょ。シンプルに。だって俺
ぶっちゃけ若い時からトップセールスだし
、トップマネージャーだしね、トップ
コンサルタントだし、個人として成果主義
やっぱりパフォーマーだよね。その僕が僕
の考え方に共感した人間が集まってきて
正直採用とま利食もありだけど採用育成と
いうことに一生懸命熱意を傾けてま38年
今240人の組織なってるけど今のこの
企業体というのはやっぱり中心に僕の哲学
があり
企業理念に共感した人間が集まって幹部に
なってるから、その幹部がやっぱり僕の
代弁もするし、もっと言うと僕じゃないね
、会社が大切にしていることを代弁できる
、語り弁になれる。そして文化そのものが
やっぱりその社会の求めに応じて最善
尽くしていこうという、そういういい文化
ができてる場合には当然発展するよね。で
、今うちも今100億の壁に向かってる
でしょう。ま、今期70億のね、台に
いよいよ乗ってきて、ま、間違いなく
100億行きますよね。で、この100億
の壁破ったら次300億に向かうわけ
じゃん。大きくしようとしてないんだよ。
だけど社会は求めてるよね、我々の仕事を
。
この社会の様々な問題を解決していく。
それから人々の願望を叶えていく。
それが事業の本質なんじゃないの?だ、そういう本質にみんなが向かってる会社、そういう会社発展するんじゃないの?そんな風に思うけどね。
ありがとうございます。青木社長から見て
いて、ま、今はまだ年少1億円ですとか、
もしくはそれよりももっと小さい規模だっ
たとしても、ま、これから本当に大きく
発展していくなっていう会社って、ま、
どんな会社で、どんな経営者の方になり
ますか?
ま、もちろんね、業種業色々あるだろう
けれど、その社会のやっぱりニーズって
いうのはやっぱ1番まず大事だと思うのよ
。やっぱ大きな社会ニーズがある。ま、
ちょっと昔産業革命の時代まず鉄じゃん。
そして石油になり、そして情報化社会が
到来して、今AIの時代だから。そうする
と反動体とか。でもうちの会社さ、それ
分かってるけどじゃあ反動体のことに興味
あるやつってあんまいないじゃん。そう
すると僕は何に関心があるかって言うと、
やっぱりどんな時代になろうともやっぱり
人が物心と共に豊かな人生を送り、その不
満足な人間関係が起因するあらゆる不幸を
この世からなくしていきたいんだと。その
ためにはどうしたらいいかって言うと、
やっぱりマネジメントスキルとか
リーダーシップの領域だとか、その様々な
コンサルティング、トレーニングアンド
コンサルティングを通してお客様の企業の
推出をよくしていこうとか、ま、家庭、
学校、そして企業、そういう不満足な人間
関係が禁する様々な問題を解決しようと
いうこれ正直
なんだろうな。その目に見えない技術、
そういうトレーニングアンド
コンサルティングカンパニーとして、ま、
ある意味ではうん、目に見える形のある
例えばBtoBのね、世界で
コンピューター関係のそういうなんか
大きな仕事とね、違ってAIの
コンサルティングとかなんかそういうもの
がまたできればいいんだけど、うちの場合
はどっちかって言うとこ人と人のこう
コミュニケーションのスキルとか
マネジメントの領域なので社員もちゃんと
育てなければいけないしトレーナーを育て
なきゃいけないしそうするとやっぱり今
まあ38年目になるけれどもま売上自体は
70億レベルの経常利益はでもま技術が
あるからま20億の計上利益は確保できる
会社の規模というよりも適正能力ってのが
あるんじゃないのでも圧倒基本的に今の
社会のニーズから考えたらAIを使った
いろんな工夫をしてこの社会の課題を解決
してこうと思ったら300億でも500億
でもこれから発展してくと思いますよ。
市場規模ってやっぱあるよね。どんな
ビジネスでも。で、社会のニーズがそこに
あるわけで、ま、私は人材教育、この領域
でしっかりと深掘りをしてお客様と共に
歩んでいきたいと思ってますけど、私は
やっぱこう一筋の道を行くとあれもこれも
じゃなくでも、ま、出版社も僕はね、経用
してるけれども、出版の方も毎年毎年事実
ね、1000億ぐらいのね、マーケットが
こう小さくなってる。でも文字がなくなっ
てるわけじゃないんだよね。その分SNS
だとかどんどん発展してるわけで、だから
紙というものに対しては確かにマーケット
小さくなってるから書店はどんどん
どんどん小さくなっていってる。でも
やっぱり世の中に必要とされる書籍は
死に相の人たちもやっぱり紙じゃなきゃ
だって人もいるわけだし、ある一定私は
売れると思いますよ。うん。だからなんか
ね、あんまりね、儲かる、儲からないって
いうよりも、今の世の中に何が必要なのか
というところに立したビジネスを
掘り裂下げていく方がきっと発展、反映
するんではないかと僕は信じてますけどね
。
結論はやっぱり社会ニーズに答えていける
だけの適正能力を有してい
るっていうことなんだけど、ま、精神的な
やっぱりこう文化的な背景、経営者がなん
だろう。目先の尊徳じゃなくて、ちゃんと
会社の仕事に対する健全な心志しと
やっぱり適正能力を持って、そして、ま、
人も物金とよく言われるけど良い人材、
理念に共感した良い人材を採用し、育成を
し、そして価値ある商品を作ったらそれを
世に広め、そしてその富の循環、それを
しっかり起こしながらやっぱり
世の中のめに応じて努力を続けてる。そしてやっぱりし志しだと思うのよ。志し志しが高ければ大きくしてくださる。それと適正能力だよね。ま、そういうことを考えてる方は反映してくんじゃないかなと。
ま、誠実でね、そして適正能力があり、
世の中の求めに応じて努力をしてる会社、
そういう会社が発展してくんだと思います
よ。え、是非ね、あのコメント欄にもね、
コメントよろしくお願いしたいと思います
。え、またチャンネル登録まだの人は是非
チャンネル登録してください。いや、
嬉しいことにね、もう本当にもうね、
こな間だ500万再生ねえ、もうクリアし
ました。ね、これから10
万人に向かって多くの人がみんな今毎日毎日ね、チャンネル登録してくれてますから皆さんも是非よろしくお願いします。頑張ります。よろしくお願いします。
[音楽]
史場の規模いよりはどちらかというと経営者の方ご本人がやっぱりこう、ま、本当にこう追求できる領域を追求していくっていうこと。
そう、やっぱ本気で打ち込める領域に打ち込んだ方がいいと思う。
だって僕営業には相当自信あるけど、ま、
正直ね、じゃあその、じゃあ反動体とかっ
てわかんないもんな、俺。いや、わかん
ないよ。感動体のことかと言って、じゃあ
例えば人材紹介の仕事とか言っても
やっぱり紹介した人に本当にあなた責任
持てるのって言われたらなかなかそれは
コミションをもらったとしてもね、その人
がしっかりと働いてくれるまでやっぱり
責任持たなきゃいけないから途中でやめ
ちゃったら俺お金返しに行かなきゃいけ
ないタイプだから性格がだ。それも
ちょっと随分昔に派遣だとか紹介の資格
取ったけど、どうしてもそこの事業に力
入れられないよね。M&Aって言ったって
確かにすごいマーケットなんですよ。だ
けどやっぱりM&A成功させようと思っ
たらそれだけの知識や本当にそういうお客
様の問題解決に寄り添って解決してか
なきゃいけないと思うからなんかもうね
契約をしてしまったらもう逃れられない
ような契約をしてとんでもないそのね
コミッション取るような今そういう
コンサルタントもいっぱいいるわけじゃん
。俺そういうの肌に合わないんだよね。だ
から色々世の中にあるけれど、やっぱり
自分の
考えるっていうか、自分の信じる価値観に
あった仕事を深掘りして、やっぱり顧客
満足の中に自分の会社の存在理由を見出し
てく方が僕は自分の肌に合ってるし、ま、
うちはそういう社員ばっかりが集まってる
んですよ。うん。だからなんだろう。経済
的合理性だけである意味であの働いてる
社員じゃないよね。でも面白いよね。大
企業にさ、経済的合理性で給料とか台遇だ
とかでいい会社って言って入って3年もし
たらやめてるやついっぱいいるわけじゃん
。だ本当に好きな仕事についてないんだよ
。これ判断間違いなんですよ。うん。だ
から僕はやっぱり自分が信じる
なんだろう価値観に基づいていい会社を
作っていく社会と共に高クリエーション共
に作り出していく協力会社と力合わせて
そういう系を貫いて社会が大きくして
くださるそういう系をしたらいいんじゃ
ないですか。うん。僕は人作りが組織作り
、組織りは国作りと思ってるので、そこに
情熱を傾けてるって感じかな。
[音楽]
決して負けない経営だ。まず経営者自身が
お金よりも仕事の内容をそのものに
掘れ込んでるかどうかな。